hi I'm Erik Bosse and Dark Phoenix as
what will probably be the final entry in
this Fox Marvel iteration of the x-men
before Marvel Studios inevitably reboots
the franchise and as a film that
struggled with repeated delays and
reshoots was far from the disaster that
reviews would have you believed now sure
it's a little weird to see a movie with
so many people rolling over unconscious
both on screen and in the audience but
hey I enjoyed this x-men movie a lot
more than I thought I would and it
actually has a number of interesting
hidden details and connections to the
comics said I want to break down for you
spoiler warning if you haven't seen it
yet and let's get started okay in the
movies opening titles the 20th Century
Fox logo features its ex emblazoned with
Phoenix e fire which lingers a few
frames longer as it fades to black which
is actually a little tradition that the
editors have worked into the past x-men
films over black the voice of Jean Grey
narrates the theme of this movie this
whole question of whether you're stuck
has a person that you've always been or
whether you can change from that echoing
the theses that Charles Xavier would
open many past x-men films with a
flashback to 1975 shows Jean Grey is a
girl in the backseat with her parents
music here is Jimmy Webb's by the time I
get to Phoenix and young Jean tries to
change the radio station reflecting her
resistance to getting to Phoenix Jean
Grey is an omega-level mutant with
psychic abilities that far exceed those
of Professor X and here as a girl her
powers become too overwhelming and she
causes the car accident that kills her
mother now there's some confusion here
over whether it was the Phoenix force
that caused this overload or just her
own super powerful telepathic and
telekinetic abilities and there has been
some question over when in the x-men
timeline that Jean acquired this Phoenix
power because yeah in x-men apocalypse
which was set in the 80s when Jean was a
teenager she did use what looked like
the Phoenix force to defeat apocalypse
in the x-men comics there's actually
some precedence of the Phoenix force
actually first encountering Jean when
she was a girl kind of imprinting on her
but laying dormant and then
rediscovering her later as an adult on
the space mission from the Dark Phoenix
saga when Phoenix and Jean Grey fully
fused with each other so yeah this story
was adapted from Chris Claremont famous
Dark Phoenix saga in the 80s in the
x-men comics an arc that this movie's
director Simon Kinberg attempted to
adapt 13 years ago when his co-writer
x-men the last stand but studio
executives downplay Jim Gray's story in
favor of the mutant cure vaccine
storyline and the whole war with
Magneto's mutant Brotherhood see back in
2006 Hollywood executives didn't really
trust that fans would actually go pay to
see movies about themes and storylines
that they already loved in the comics
but anyway Charles recruits Jean to join
his school for the gifted telling her
that he can fix her and she's not broken
which he does by creating walls in her
mind to block out the trauma the car
accident and block out the memory of her
father abandoning her out of fear in
this way Dark Phoenix cast Charles and a
morally ambiguous light that some of the
comics have done questioning Charles
Xavier choices to turn scared kids and
to commandos and public superheroes so
we jump ahead to 1990 to the present
year of this story and the year that the
x-men characters went mainstream with
x-men the animated series there's a
crisis with NASA's Space Shuttle
Endeavor so like first class did with
the Cuban Missile Crisis and Days of
Future past did with Richard Nixon this
x-men movie is using real history as a
backdrop for its story kind of telling
an alternate history like three Shuttle
Endeavor didn't explode I just saw it
here in LA I thought I did so Charles
deploys the x-men which in this movie
include Hank McCoy beast Nicholas Hoult
Raven mystique Jennifer Lawrence and
Peter Maximoff Quicksilver Evan Peters
who after being one of the best things
about the last two x-men movies sadly
gets about as much screen time as he did
in that cameo in Deadpool 2 there's also
the noobs who were introduced in x-men
apocalypse
Scott Summers Cyclops ty Sheridan Jean
Grey sophie Turner Kurt Wagner
Nightcrawler Kodi smit-mcphee and Aurora
Monroe storm Alexandra ship the x-men
where these new simplified costumes that
seem to be drawn from the Frank Quitely
designs from the new x-men by Grant
Morrison they're also a bit similar to
director Matthew Vaughn's x-men first
class costumes really just embracing the
classic blue and yellow color scheme
Raven actually calls us out to Charles
later on suggesting the simplicity was
intentional as part of Charles PR
branding strategy for the team as
opposed to just like random blue
jumpsuits or random black leather
costumes the extra jet takes off from
under the basketball court and they
included the same shot of the rolling
basketball that we saw from the Jets
take off in the first x-men movie the
x-men saved the astronauts but Jean
absorbs the cosmic nebulous Phoenix
force which helps her
survive in space and when she lands on
the surface it starts to feel real good
kind of like Caine and alien feeling
real good eat noodles but wait evil
alien force inside him bad news
Jean and Skye go to this bonfire party
with a few cameos of other x-men
characters lighting the fire is matched
Ben Hamill played by Lamar Johnson they
also arrive via portal suggesting that
blink is hanging out there's also
Dazzler singing and making pretties
played by Houston sage Dazzler is
actually introduced during the Dark
Phoenix saga as a disco Queen superhero
where they want to spin-off with her own
movies meanwhile the villains of this
movie arrived the alien race of the
d'bari now the d'bari were also from the
dark phoenix comics as a race that got
annihilated when Dark Phoenix flew off
into space to recharge and feasted on a
star destroying the d'bari solar system
leaving only a few survivors later in
this movie it's mentioned that these
d'bari are the few survivors of this
race suggesting that the Phoenix force
could have done this to their people in
the movie universe as well sometime in
the past and now the d'bari are hoping
to gain the weapon of the Phoenix force
to restart their culture on earth these
aliens are discovered at a dinner party
where Jessica Chastain actually plays a
human party host who goes to check on a
barking dog named Luna Luna could be a
reference to Luna maxima from the comics
who's the daughter of Quicksilver and
crystal the first child born of a mutant
in an inhuman now these de bourree are
shape shifters suggesting that maybe in
an earlier version of this movie they
might have actually been scrolls or
super scrolls scrolls are a marvel
property of shapeshifters we saw them in
Captain Marvel super scrolls though at
the time of shooting this movie were
still a Fox Marvel property since
they're more commonly associated with a
fantastic for now the castles movie
recently hinted that the studio had to
reshoot huge portions of Dark Phoenix
due to some accidental similarities with
another superhero movie it's probably
Captain Marvel since Captain Marvel
featured the shape-shifting squirrel
race aunt Jessica Chastain said that her
character was changed so much that in
research she never really knew who she
was playing oops
the leader of the d'bari takes on
Chastain's appearance and is named Luke
Luke is a character from Marvel Comics
also known as star Hammer who used human
disguises to sneak around uses
technology to turn Avengers into stone
he was later actually revealed as the
last surviving tabari due to be an awful
when Phoenix ate their star durian
Charles Xavier speech at the White House
chris claremont actually makes a cameo
he was the writer the dark phoenix
comics and really it's good they
included them because he was among those
most responsible for keeping the whole
x-men popular in the 80s really turning
them into the household name that they
are today Jean goes to look for her
father in Red Hook New York which is a
town that actually came up in the x-men
universe before like in the FX series
Legion which is co-produced by Dark
Phoenix director Simon Kinberg in the
pilot episode it featured the discovery
of David Haller who liked seen is an
omega-level mutant and they had a
division three mentioned a Red Hook
incident after what I haven't in Red
Hook Wednesday that's an understatement
and the background of this town there's
a truck with a logo bishop power a nod
to Bishop the human who can absorb
energy and release it from his bodies a
constant conductor of radiation
electricity the x-men tried to stop Jean
but she takes him out one by one
including fatally Raven she impales
Raven on these three spikes and there's
actually an interesting detail in Ravens
death here but before I continue thanks
to rise of the Kings for sponsoring this
episode rise of the Kings is a war
strategy mobile games set in the Middle
Ages but with fantasy elements so if
you're just a sophie turner fan you saw
in game of thrones but we should end it
differently here's your chance to show
how dragons and castles should play out
in the same way that jean grey says it
feels good to go in rage mode as Phoenix
it feels pretty sweet to use a dragon
burn the Lich and rise with Kings
yeah it feels a bit different when
you're the one doing the burning doesn't
it rise the Kings feature is a bunch of
hero options with varying stats styles
and features with beautifully done
artwork now building up the heroes
involves the formation of troops and
promotion of attributes but on looks
alone I got to hand it to Asher hi now
that it's fierce you can also experience
what it's like when your castle is being
attacked play defense with your own
intricate defense strategy rise of the
Kings has global servers so you can
compete with players from all over the
world can also set up your own alliance
chat with friends from around the globe
and get to waging war together so what
are you waiting for download rise of the
Kings now using our download link in the
description below can also get a free
gift pack with our unique code in the
description okay back to Mystique's
death it actually brings her full circle
with the original Mystique's fake death
from Wolverines claws in the first x-men
three spikes cutting
her midsection and speaking of Wolverine
this emotional death echoes the death of
Logan who also bled out after being
impaled I guess this is the one way we
can horribly kill x-men characters after
berry and Raven Hank and Charles Duke it
out grieving in the kitchen Charles
recalls this location as the place where
he met Raven a callback to the scene in
x-men first class actually earlier and
Raven realized that they were the last
of the first class reminding us of other
first class members like Alex Summers
slash havoc who died in apocalypse and
Sean Cassidy slash banshee who has
revealed in Days of Future past who have
been captured and experimented on it
also reminds us how weird it was that
Nicholas Hoult Jennifer Lawrence James
McAvoy and Michael Fassbender were all
in Cuba in 1962 but look more or less
exactly the same 30 years later and I
guess eight years from now they're gonna
age into Kelsey Grammer Rebecca romaine
Patrick Stewart and Ian McKellen I know
it's confusing but Mikey's on it Jean
Grey finds Erik Lehnsherr magneto on his
mutant island colony and in the credits
one of those guards is listed as Genosha
century so this colony is indeed Genosha
in the comics magneto established
Genosha as an all mutants nation of his
own to command notice that all the
structures Sarah metallic there's
shipping crates a hull of a boat
remember in x-men apocalypse magneto
nearly destroyed the planet by
unearthing all the metal in the soil in
the cities we saw the shipping crates
like these flying off a boats and then
holes being dragged off the ocean floor
maybe magneto did the same thing to
build Genosha here joining Magneto's
team in this movie are mutants Selene
played by coda Aberhart in the comics
she's a member of the Hellfire Club in a
super powerful telepath but in this
movie she gets abruptly yanked out of a
trained orc sure there's also a new
character not from the comics a rekey
played by Andrew Steele in we thought he
was gonna be Red Lotus in this movie but
here he appears to use his braids as
whips and lasses sure Jean except an
army helicopter and Eric says get so she
meets Luke who explains to her that the
Phoenix forces side Jean is the spark
that ignited the universe with godlike
abilities to destroy and create Hank
tells magneto that Jean killed Raven and
Erik tearfully retrieves his old magneto
helmet which he keeps in a locker where
a newspaper is barely visible that
headline reads news cameras capture
white house's of
this is from Magneto and Ravens attack
on the White House in x-men Days of
Future past now the moment magneto puts
on his helmet
the editors cut directly to Charles
taking off his cerebro helmet and
Charles takes Scott storm and
Nightcrawler to confront magneto Hank
and Selene and Ricky as they tried to
kill gene in Bucks mansion but it
doesn't work magneto almost gets his
eyes poked out gene humiliates Charles
by dragging his body up the stairs very
unsettling and Jane and Boog hug it out
with the Phoenix force spreading some
what in the book now this whole idea of
sharing the Phoenix force among multiple
superheroes might have come from the
Avengers vs. x-men comics when Ironman
blasted Phoenix force with the disrupter
fracturing it into five pieces that
possessed Cyclops
Emma Frost colossus magic and Namor
turning them into the Phoenix five that
rule the earth for a brief period of
time the x-men get taken by the MCU and
I saw you did there in this case the
mutant containment unit who takes them
into captivity via train with each of
them in these mutant inhibitor collars
similar to the ones from Deadpool - and
this whole train sequence is really the
most fun part of the film and it was
actually the main sequence that was
added in reshoots for the movie
originally dark Phoenix's finale didn't
have this it was going to be set in
space as Phoenix blows up a bunch of
alien ships but yeah that's essentially
what happened in the final act of
Captain Marvel so they reconfigured this
battle to be on the train where are you
sure it's not totally clear who the
d'bari villains are what they can do
like some guns can kill them but others
can't but hey at least we get to see
magneto be magneto again crushing a
train car around a bunch of d'bari and
tossing it like a crumpled soda can
apparently the reshoots also included a
redesign of Jean Grey's Phoenix force
energy which was going to be fiery
flapping around her body like the
traditional design for the character but
since Captain Marvel's binary energy
looked super fiery - they changed it
here so that the Phoenix force looks
like fiery vanes
spreading from under her skin sure also
they removed my favorite clip from the
trailer when Scott and Charles screamed
big boy voices at each other tell me
what to do I don't know watch it and I
don't know why you cut out
Jean kills the rest of the d'bari it
takes Luke to space tells her to go [ __ ]
herself and leaves the x-men and movies
epilogue they renamed Charles school to
Jean Grey school for the gifted
youngsters a nod
to the comics where Wolverine renames it
the Jean Grey school for higher learning
and we see that Charles has retired to
Paris where Erik Lehnsherr finds them
and talks him into another game of chess
an oddity long-running tradition between
these two characters seen in the ending
of the first x-men and more recently in
Days of Future past and actually the
name of this Cafe is cafe le vous copain
translating - I never took French so
shut up about pronunciation also cafe of
old friends and as Phoenix appears
flying in the distance over their heads
similar to Phoenix's tease of a return
at the end of X - jeans voiceover
returns saying this is not the end of me
or the x-men this is a new beginning a
reminder that whatever we feel about the
x-men right now a new beginning is in
the works
thanks to fix it by key comment down
below with your thoughts on Dark Phoenix
follow me on instagram and twitter at EA
vas and subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdowns into everything you love
thank you for joining me and what do you
think we should do with all this time
until Feige brings back the x-men I
don't know watch a German sorry I asked